ceci n'est pas une libellule mais une
demoiselle elle est plus petite moins
trapu et garde ses ailes repliées le
long du dos pour observer les
différences entre ces insectes
aquatiques 20 clichés sont exposés à la
Maison de l'Environnement de Manille
amour jusqu'au 31 mai une chance de
pouvoir observer ses insectes plutôt
difficile à photographier ça dépend un
peu du coup de chance il y avoir des
clichés qui vont être faits en
5 minutes parce que la libellule a bien
voulu rester en place et d'autres qui
vont mettre une demi-heure trois quarts
d'heure parce qu'elle arrête pas de
bouger s'il fait chaud les insectes sont
très vif et on aura beaucoup plus de mal
à
ce qui reste en place alors que quand il
fait froid ils sont un peu plus calme
armée d'un objectif macro Fabien viré a
traqué ces modèles dans la réserve
naturelle du Pinail dans la Vienne 135
hectares plus de 5000 mares un cadre
idéal qui concentre 48 espèces de
libellules différentes sur les 90
existantes c'est d'ailleurs opina et que
Fabien viré a commencé la photo en 2007
et à côté de ses clichés un atelier
découverte et proposé aux enfants les
libellules les demoiselles n'auront plus
aucun secret pour eux